- [Mark] Okay, Melvina.
Melvina, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I'm originally from
Sanostee, New Mexico.
That's on my mom's side, Dala Silversmith.
But we reside in Oak Springs,
and that's on my dad's
side, Melvin Silversmith.
- [Mark] And you're Navajo?
- I'm a full-blooded Navajo.
My plans are the (speaking Navajo)
Those are my plans.
I'm a proud mother of two.
I have 10 siblings.
Nine actually, four
brothers, two passed on.
God bless their soul.
I'm 6th. It's five
sisters, six with me, so.
I'm the baby of the
family. I'm the youngest.
I was taught a lot by my parents.
I have two different
personalities from both parents
but combining both personalities
that are coming out through
having a big heart yourself.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- My childhood was pretty good.
I was being well taken care
of, but I always got picked on.
I always wanted to go
with my parents somewhere,
but they always chose
my brother before me,
Merwin Silversmith.
- [Mark] And did you finish high school?
- I didn't finish high school,
but I did go to Crownpoint.
I went for my GED,
and I took nursing class on the side.
I pretty much know a lot.
I know carpentry, mechanic.
I can build you a house if
you wanna shack out here,
for those, like us natives.
I'll use a cardboard box.
But my two kids are safe.
They're staying with my ex
sister-in-law, Winifred Watson.
- [Mark] So you don't raise your kids?
- No, I gave her custody.
I miss my kids so much,
but with this virus going on,
I ain't trying to harm my kids
or my ex in-laws in any way for that.
- [Mark] So you're living on the street?
- Living on the streets.
- [Mark] Here in Gallup, New Mexico.
- Here in Gallup, New Mexico.
- [Mark] And so, are you
using drugs or alcohol?
Alcohol is your thing?
- Alcohol.
- [Mark] How long has alcohol
been a part of your life?
- It's been a part of my
life since high school.
Actually, I think mid
school at eighth grade.
That's when I first got hit
up by broomstick by my mom
because we were brought up well,
but in our lifetime, we messed up.
And the reason why I'm out here is
because I wanted to show my people,
I have a home, I have
a land, I have a ride.
I put all that aside
to live like my people,
to show my people I love them.
Every little thing I have,
this is all I got right here.
- [Mark] What is your drink of choice?
Is it...
(Melvina clears throat)
- My drink of choice?
- [Mark] What do you go to most?
- Hello? This is Gallup,
New Mexico, it's importers.
I've got importer from 505 to 928.
Fallen back on 505, so that's my import.
And that's the best alcohol
that would cure a hangover.
- [Mark] And what is that?
- Importers.
- [Mark] But, when you
say importers, what do-
- Importer Vodka.
- [Mark] Vodka, okay.
And do you start drinking
typically in the evening?
- No, I would buy-
- [Mark] Cause you're not drunk right now.
- No, I would buy a half a gallon,
and it would last me for
like two or three days,
just walking the streets all night.
I hardly get rest,
but I'm just glad that I
know that nobody's hurt.
Sharing just that little
sip, helping someone else.
That really means a lot,
and how much they really appreciate it.
- [Mark] So you share your vodka?
- Mm hmm. I'm not stingy.
Every little thing I
have, I'll give it out.
Like my last meal, and that's
a meal I just barely got,
I'll give it to whoever's hungry.
Or I would tell them to share
or the last drink, a bottle,
or I'll give out pints.
The way I make money is...
I wouldn't say that.
Question mark. Sell things.
But I've been finding
stuff on the streets,
brand new stuff.
I don't know if it was stolen,
but instead of selling it back,
I give it out.
Give it to the most person that needs it.
Like the brand new Nike
shoes I gave away yesterday.
And that Nike shoe was like
over 179 or almost 200.
Man, living these streets is not...
But, I can actually say it's fun
how you make ends meet with each day.
How you gonna survive?
How are you gonna keep yourself warm?
- [Mark] Sometimes people die
on the streets from the cold, right?
- Yeah. If you overdo
your drugs and alcohol.
Okay, I'm not gonna beat around the bush.
When I first came out last year
and in July, I think it was.
It was like August,
but it was sometimes last year,
I spent almost eight months out here.
And one guy came up to me, which
I haven't seen to this day.
He gave me a drink of Vodka Importers.
He goes, "I know what you're here for.
I know what you're about.
You're one of them good people."
He goes, "Take a shot at this."
So he gave me a bottle, and I took a shot,
and he goes, "I'm gonna give you heads up.
This, don't take it to get drunk.
This, think of it right,
and it'll keep you warm."
And that was during the cold.
And then he bust out a bud,
like one of those drug buds.
It was loaded,
and I didn't know how to
smoke it, and he taught me.
And he goes, "I'm telling you this
because you're here for your people."
And I said, "I don't do
drugs. I don't smoke weed."
And he goes, "Just take this,
and I'll tell you what it's about."
So I took the first hit
and not knowing people were following me,
and people that wanted jump me
for helping out the elderlies
and getting their stuff back.
And he told me this will keep you alert.
This will tell you, "be careful."
This is gonna give you a heads up
on who's coming from behind you.
Not knowing better and
actually thinking of it,
and then thinking about always how smoke,
we looked through smoke ashes,
and I thought about that.
The whole time I was out here,
I took alcohol and drugs,
but I used it in a good way,
not in a bad way.
I help people. I help elderlies.
I help them survive.
I've seen things that
I should've not seen.
I could say I've seen the unexplainable,
the unexpectable, but I
explored that adventure.
- [Mark] What's the most
extreme thing you've seen
in your time here on the street?
- My most extreme?
I've seen a guy who's the
opposite of a Navajo medicine man.
I've seen him get lifted
up off the ground frozen.
And that guy did not like me.
The day I seen him get lifted
and put it into an ambulance all frozen,
I cried, and I prayed.
Prayer means a lot.
But by morning,
the next morning, I got up and I was like,
"Damn, I was worried
about the guy so much."
Next you know, he was walking right there
in front of (indistinct)
I just told my uncle to stop.
I jumped off.
I ran to him, and I said,
"Dude, can I get a hug?"
And he said, "For what?"
I go, "I've seen you die yesterday."
And I said,
"Just right there between
(indistinct) and Third Street."
I said, "The way they lifted
you, you were frozen, Dude."
And I said, "I'm sorry,
but it means a lot that
my prayers did go through
because you're still here
walking in the morning."
And stupid me, I had drinks, I had hits,
and I told him, I said, "Hey
guy, I'm not gonna do this.
I hate to do this, but shoot, man,
it's nice to see you alive."
I offer him that shot, offer him hits,
and then he said he was
brought back to life.
I've seen an older lady get
jumped by three teenagers.
Shoot, I go back, and I told them,
"What if that was your mom,
your sister, or your grandma?
Would you like it? Seeing it?
You give her stuff back. She don't drink.
She don't do drugs.
Can't you guys see that?"
And they gave her a cut
on her left eyebrow.
- [Melvina] People think it's funny.
They think life is funny.
They make fun of life.
That's why they're where
they're at right now,
stealing from other people.
If you help somebody out,
shoot, God has something
in return ahead of you.
I find free things.
I find brand new shoes.
And it's only telling me to pass it on.
Somebody claims it's
theirs, and I tell them,
"Look, I've seen you out here for so long,
and you think it's your
shoe when you stole it?"
Why hang on to something
you stole? Pass it on.
Because that person you stole
from is not gonna ever get it back,
but they'll see another person wearing it.
And for people to be discriminating,
being disrespectful,
the only way you're gonna live out here,
you're gonna survive is by your own self,
your being honest, you have loyalty,
be independent to live on the streets.
You help one, you shall receive help.
Either way, it works.
You disrespect people, you
get that same disrespect.
How are you gonna get respect
when you make fun of a person?
If they're disabled, if they can't walk,
they fall over, shoot,
you go over there and lift their hand.
You don't just watch them
and make fun of them.
Most people out here
think they know better.
All the dealers, they're all gone.
Now, I told them,
"You guys are disrespecting so much
that it's gonna come back worse on you."
However is the B-I-T-C-H.
- [Mark] Is there a sex work here?
Sex trafficking going on in New Mexico?
- Sex trafficking?
I know like some of the hotels,
they have room for prostitute,
and it's my own native girls.
But what they get out of it is $5.
They get a drink. They just get one shot.
Some shoot up.
You see them normal, happy,
but once they get on that,
they're a whole different person.
It's like...
How would you call it?
They're making fun of themselves,
but they don't know that drugs,
alcohol is making them look stupid.
All these girls here, they're parents,
not one acts like one.
They act like gangsters.
They act like they can hurt somebody.
But shoot, once a guy, backhands them,
they're the ones crying, running.
For me, as a mother of two,
I'm proud to have my beautiful kids.
I'm glad they're safe and alive.
But I ain't out here to beat another guy.
I ain't out here to start trouble.
I'm out here to show
love and caring again.
I just tell them, "Hey
man, love you guys."
- [Mark] So why you on the streets
rather than with your children?
- My children are safe.
After quarantine, my sister got it twice,
her and her girlfriend,
and I risked my life to
be out here to watch her.
The girlfriend won't take her home.
She messed up my sister's face so bad
that her face is barely healing.
I tell them. I watch over them.
They sleep on top of the
bridge on Third Street.
I'm afraid that the girlfriend
might push her off that bridge.
And I stay at the bottom looking out,
not just watching my sister,
I'm watching everybody.
Walkway is a dangerous place.
I mean, one person, so little,
makes themselves look big.
I say, "Hey, little big men."
I say, "You don't got no balls
to be treating your people like this."
I got guys sent out to me.
I got a knife pulled out to me last night.
And I took my sister and her girlfriend,
and I said, "You guys, don't be around me,
but just stay somewhere
where they won't see you."
And I haven't seen them since last night.
- [Mark] Do you relate
to your Navajo heritage?
- My Navajo heritage? Yeah, I do.
I'm a hand trembler in a good way.
I'm here to let people know, "Watch out."
It's not like in no bad way.
I heal people.
I'm just glad that I have the most
two loving caring parents
who taught us well.
I don't know if I get it from my mom
or my dad's side, but the
bond of love, I'm showing it.
I've seen people get off
the street from my words.
I haven't seen them, but I
do see them other places.
They give me a hug,
and they tell me my words
are of encouragement.
I'm an independent person.
I'm not out here to make fun,
not to act like a fool.
I'm not out here to fight people.
But when it comes to a point,
that point will become a point.
How else are you gonna survive?
They take stuff from
you, and you see someone.
They're trying to make you fight.
My own people would be like that.
And that's not right.
I'm out here to show love, caring,
how it feels to have love again.
Ain't nobody showing it.
I gave up everything,
and this is all I got.
I'm ashamed to ask for money.
I'm ashamed to be like,
"Can I borrow some change?"
But damn, I'm glad I'm still alive,
and I still see my
people alive the next day
with a smile.
People discriminate us, other racists,
when my people panhandle,
telling them to get a job.
They don't know what we're going through.
We are the first ones that suffered.
We are the ones that went
into our world to survive.
We went through the long walk, shoot.
You might even be Navajo
too. You don't know it.
You have a color of Navajo on you.
(indistinct) what's up Ninja?
But I always show love to everybody.
I try to keep a drink on me
because anxiety is not a funny thing.
You see people get DTs,
anxiety, falling over.
People just make fun and walk off.
The guy's suffering. The lady's suffering.
Who does that?
I would do anything to
lend a hand, lend a finger.
Most people say, "I got your back."
How are they gonna get your back
when they just run off
when you get into trouble?
When someone steps up to you,
I tell my people, I got your front.
I'll take a hit for
you, but I'll dodge it.
So you don't know if I'll throw fake left,
but I'll knock you out with the right.
I'll straight out kick you
in your face without knowing.
- [Melvina] I'm not here to fight.
I'm here to love and care for people.
And to see them not around,
shoot, I save lives.
- [Mark] All right, Melvina.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- But you might be my native,
so I'm glad I did this.
But my natives, I love them.
(Mark chuckles)
But they're my ninjas.
- [Mark] All right,
Melvina, thank you so much.
- Thank you so much.
And just, love you, mom and dad.
Love you Delilah, Jana
Watson, my beautiful kids.
(lips smacking)